basically what the hinge theorem says is
that if we have two sides in one
triangle that are congruent to two sides
in another triangle but the angle okay
that's in between those two congruent
sides is different okay you can see here
this is 30 here this is 40 what we can
do is we can look across okay diagonally
across from that angle the one that's
across from the larger angle is going to
be the longer side and that's why they
call it a hinge theorem because you can
see like this hand my right hand in my
left hand if I open up that angle to a
larger extent right the side across from
that angle is gonna be longer so it's
pretty obvious but just you know we want
to go over this nonetheless so with the
converse of the hinge theorem what we're
talking about here is they're actually
giving us three side links notice that
these two side links are congruent to
these two side links but what's
different between these two triangles is
that see how this side is eight this
side is twelve which angle do you think
is larger angle a or angle B well if you
said angle B you're absolutely right so
that's greater and the reason is is
because to accommodate that side twelve
we have to open up this hinge wider
right so this angle B is going to be
larger than angle a now what happens if
these were exactly the same
you know let's say they were both eight
or both 12 then the two angles would be
congruent and you probably member this
from when you learn about congruent
triangles that would be the side side
side triangle congruence theorem meaning
that if three sides are congruent to
three sides
everything in those triangles is going
to be exactly the same it's going to be
an exact match so let's jump into some
examples see if you can do these and
we'll go over them so this first one
example one look at what we've got we've
got a six eight and five six eight and
four and we're trying to figure out is
angle a larger or angle F larger we're
comparing those two well again notice we
have six and eight six and eight okay so
those two sides that are making up the
angle right those two sides are making
up that angle what we have to do is we
have to look across okay from that angle
and what do you notice here you've got
five versus four five is greater than
four that means that angle a must be
opening up wider right then angle
so here we have angle a is greater than
angle F okay let's go to example number
two now here this is a little bit
different setup you can see these two
triangles are right next to one another
they're sharing this side right here
okay DB so DB is congruent to itself by
reflexive and we can see that DC is
congruent to da so we have two sides
okay that are congruent to two sides in
this triangle but what's different is
the angle that's in between those two
sides here thirty degrees is going to be
opening wider than 25 degrees so you can
see that BC is going to be greater than
a B ok example three you can see that
we've got two triangles okay you can see
that they're sharing this side right
here the side 80 it's 10 units long but
notice that you've got 10 and 6 and
you've got 10 and 6 but what's different
is that the side across from this angle
here okay is shorter than the side
that's across from this angle over here
so we're trying to compare angle SAT SAT
that's this angle versus ATC that's this
angle but again notice you have those
two sides they're congruent but what's
different is the angle in between here
what we're doing is we're looking across
from the angle and you can see that 8 is
longer than 7 which means that this
angle has to be opening wider right so
this is the converse of the hinge
theorem and you can see that this is
going to be ATC is going to be greater
than angle SAT